all right you're done let's look at the
solution all right we'll move to weather
provider we start by creating a third
selection query up at the top of our
provider much like the second query
except that we search for the exact date
rather than a greater than or equal date
we then add a function that uses the
weather contract functions to get the
date and postal code from the URI we use
the new query we just wrote and the same
SQLite query builder we used before
since it only defines the join and then
we just call this function in the
weather with location and dates which
statement in our query that's it those
are all the queries we plan to use for
sunshine but we still need to test let's
go back to test provider as you can see
our test has a very very good model
already
let's fix up some of these old tests and
close the weather cursor now we can
simply copy this tests over it turns out
that the exact same data is required for
our new URI all we have to do is build
weather location with date instead of
saying weather location with start date
and we should get the same result let's
see if that's really true by running our
tests and our tests pass so we now
implemented all of the queries but we're
not done with our content provider yet
after all we're not writing any data
into the database through our content
provider